تايوان تجد نفسها واقعه بين القوتين
العظميين الصين والولايات المتحده
ومسؤولون حاليا وسابقون يتجهون الى
الدولتين الرئيسه الحاليه لتايوان
ستقوم بزياره الى حليفتي تايوان غواتيمالا
على ان تقوم بالتوقف في نيويورك ذها
من المتوقع ان ترتقي رئيسه تايوان برئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي من مكارتي في لوس
انجلوس في الخامس من الشهر المقبل فيما
يبدو لقاء مصمما لتجنب الاحداث التي تلت
زياره نانسي بلوسي العام الماضي الى
تايوان التي رفضت التعامل مع تايم منذ
انتخابها عام 2016 رفعت شكوى للولايات
المتحده بشان الزياره واتهمت الرئيسه
بالترويجي لاستقلال تايوان
الامريكي مكارثى سيكون هذا استفزازا اخر
ينتهك بشكل خطير مبدا الصين الواحده ويؤذي
سياده الصين وسلامتها الاقليميه ويدمر
السلامه والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان نحن
نعارض ذلك بشده وسنتخذ بالتاكيد اجراءات
للرد بحزم
من جانبها قالت ان تايوان دوله ذات سياده
بالفعل ولا حاجه لاعلان الاستقلال تايوان
ستشهد انتخابات رئاسيه في يناير القادم
وفي خضم الاستعدادات لها زرع الرئيس
السابق ما
الصين موجها رساله للتقارب بينما اسمائهم
الصينيين على جانبي مضيق تايوان ما بات
اول مسؤول تايواني رفيع يزور الصين لزياره
ضريح سانيات الذي ينظر عليه على انه الاب
الروحي لتايوان واطلق عليه بعد وفاته لقب
ابو الامه